pierre nicolas et michel mézières ont pu
ont pu se rendre assez rapidement ce
matin sur sur les lieux même de
l'explosion
regardez le reportage on la reconnaît à
peine et pourtant il s'agit bien de la
rocade de toulouse
il est 10h30 soit 3 à 4 minutes après
l'explosion
le complexe chimique à l'origine de
l'accident se trouve à droite à environ
150 mètres il n'en reste rien sur la
rocade des automobilistes air hagard et
hébétée il commence à réaliser ce qui
vient de leur arriver
on a eu une grande vous regardiez sonata
pas en voiture comme une bombe qui a
explosé là bas labatt
voilà ma fille eton visuel a essayé de
garder la maîtrise du jour d'une semaine
c'est un accident si incroyable john
coup comme ça car on voulait depuis son
explosion
c'est tout on entendu une grosse
explosion sur place les automobilistes
centraide et commence à organiser les
premiers secours en tentant de nous
approcher
nous passons d'abord devant la société
nationale des poudres et explosifs il y
a des blessés mais l'explosion n'est pas
venue de là le spectacle de dévastation
nous attend un peu plus loin sur le site
dit de la grande paroisse et un complexe
pétrochimique déjà ancien et dont la
présence aux portes de la ville est
dénoncée depuis longtemps
on y fabrique des engrais à parcé
ammoniac d'habitude
deux à trois cents personnes travaillent
à cet endroit dont il ne reste
absolument rien des bâtiments de béton
ou voler en éclats des voitures et
wagons et des camions ont été déformés
par le souffle de l'explosion
dans toulouse mène il me reste guère de
vitrage dans un rayon estimée entre 3 et
5 km le bilan de cette catastrophe sera
trio